district we are in today could not be
here and i'm glad to be here
representing the entire board
i want to welcome you to the coven 19
testing site here at unlv
this is a collaborative effort to
partnership with clark county as i
mentioned
the clark county fire department umc
and the nevada national guard all of
these partners have been
tremendous in helping us make sure that
we
are getting as many people tested as
possible it's been an incredible
undertaking
and it couldn't have been possible
without literally thousands of people
who've
made this happen so i want to thank them
today we're going to hear from greg may
unlv emergency management coordinator
excuse me dr louis medina garcia umc
infectious disease physician
travis haldeman clark county fire
department engineer
and he's the on-site incident commander
overseeing this incredible
i also want to thank the members of the
media who are here today to spread the
word about getting tested
on clark county's response to making
sure that as many of our residents get
tested as possible
the partnership with the media has been
what has
really allowed us to get the word out
and has allowed us the opportunity to
get as many people tested in such an
organized fashion
as you've seen from so many of our
previous sites the organization
thanks to the nevada national guard and
so many others has been incredible
we've tested through this process one
hundred thirty three thousand
six hundred and fifty one uh residents
of our community
and a hundred and twenty a hundred and
twelve thousand of those were tested at
community sites just like this one
including 56 245 tests were conducted
right here on this site
as a drive through so as you know we've
been operating the drive-throughs which
have worked out very well
they have had some challenges not the
least of which is the extremely high
temperatures
so i want to particularly thank unlv the
administration for stepping up in a big
way
to help move us indoors so that we can
have a cool climate controlled
environment
for everybody to get tested safely
spaced out and efficiently
unlv from the moment this was raised
stepped up at the time
president miana picked took the call
immediately and stepped up in a big way
with her colleagues
here on campus to make sure that we can
make this happen
and again has been a real partner and
collaborator in this effort
testing as you know is the most critical
way that we can
monitor what's happening in our
community and how we get back to work
as quickly as possible and open things
up
as the tourism hub for the united states
and really globally
we need to be setting an example for the
world of how you do it the right way
and these testing sites in my view have
been a good example of that
so we're going to sort of hear from all
the speakers here today who've been part
of this effort
then travis is going to lead us on a
tour of this facility and answer any
questions you might have
in your effort to help us get out the
word so if i could bring to the podium
greg may
unlv emergency management coordinator
and thank you
for your effort greg
well good morning and thank you
commissioner appreciate everybody coming
out to take a look at the facility
i can say that without reservation the
unlv leadership
and university police services is
extremely proud to see this
come together in such a way we're very
appreciative
of the community partners that we've
been working with
clark county fire department umc the
national guard everybody has
really stepped up we've had some safety
concerns that needed to be addressed we
had to find a location that we could do
this
in a safe manner that we were able to
segregate
the students that are going to be
returning the campus in a couple of
weeks that they wouldn't be
intermingling in traffic we segregated
a portion of our parking uh just
dedicated to the test site and i just
couldn't be happier with the
cooperation that we've received from our
partners
every time that we had a question they
were there to
change make changes adjust and i'm just
really pleased to see this
finally come together and thanks for
coming out
i would just like to bring up dr luis
medina garcia to the podium thank you
good morning everyone i'm dr louis
median garcia infectious disease doctor
for umc
thank you for having me here today and
allow me to
thank everyone for the incredible
efforts in continuing these
testing sites that are critical to the
response of nevada against this virus
we have tested a huge amount of patients
as they were mentioning before
and that is really important to know
where we stand and know what we need to
do
to continue to improve this is a new
site
the weather is probably the most
important reason why we brought this
indoors
and we have made some changes to the
progress and the
process of taking the samples and our
incident commander will talk to us more
about that later
through these incredible collaborations
we've been able to continue to offer
these tests
and partner with the community that to
keep us safe
so i exhort you to continue
your efforts in wearing masks socially
distance
stay home if you're sick and seek care
when you feel ill a lot of people are
i think still a little worried about
picking up covet in the hospitals
we have made it as safe as possible
please don't delay medical care that is
necessary
continue your efforts and and thank you
so much for helping us control this
disease
now i would like to introduce travis
helderman the incident commander for
this site
thank you dr medina um i'd also like to
say thank you to the
umc staff that you see sitting at these
tables around here
they're the ones that register everyone
we get and check and make sure
verify all their information is correct
so patients can have access to their
test results
as soon as possible uh thank you greg
may
also sir for letting us move inside i
would be swept my butt off outside if it
wasn't for you guys
so we really appreciate you guys letting
us use this space
um being in a climate controlled
atmosphere obviously makes it a lot more
comfortable
for myself the other people working here
and also the public coming in to get a
test
i'd like to say thank you to
commissioner naft for coming out today
showing your support it's awesome you're
welcome here anytime
thank you to chief steinbeck at the
clark county fire department
for really stepping up to the plate and
doing our part to handle
the pandemic for southern nevada i'd
also like to say thank you to chief
samuels of the clark county office of
emergency management
uh getting us everything we need and
really handling anything we ask of you
it's been awesome you never say no
also like to say thank you to the nevada
national guard uh
everything you see here in this building
uh has been touched or put down
moved up and downstairs multiple times
by that national guard
they're really the manpower and
workforce that
is necessary for an operation like this
to take effect so thank you
thank you to the media for coming out
today without you guys we wouldn't be
able to get our message out to the
public we really appreciate you
and that message is this we're really
encouraging people the public to
self-schedule
appointments this will increase our
efficiency here is also and it will also
reduce
sorry reduce wait times uh when you come
here
that being said we're still taking
walk-up appointments um sorry
just walk-ups people without an
appointment on a first-come first-served
basis
uh those wait times will be a little bit
longer than if you were
[Music]
registered
i'm in a moment i will give you guys all
a tour of this site
uh we will uh talk about the whole
process start to finish
and then we've got some volunteers that
will do some self swabbing for you
before we do that i'd like to open it up
to any questions you might have
you guys being too nice
yes sir
okay folks i think what we're going to
do is we're going to crack all this down
so we have more
better visuals so give us a second to
get this out of the way if you want to
pull out your mic
and then we can follow him around on the
door and like i said we'll
break it